today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the china virus that
will save countless lives
[Music]
of recovered convalescence to help treat
patients battling a current infection
[Music]
convalescence today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the china virus that
will
save countless lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
[Music]
convalescence
[Music]
nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
i just left walters
and i learned so much in monovirus
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have the best
medical equipment oh be afraid of it
feel great like better than i have in a
long time
[Music]
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm amused i don't know be afraid
of it don't let it dominate don't let it
take over your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world you're
afraid of it as your leader i had to do
that i knew there's danger do it but i
had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there be careful
we have the best medicines in the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
[Music]
i love mangoes
too now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango
my mangoes is down
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected
and highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
wow what an incredible introduction that
is quickly becoming one of my favorite
songs in the entire uh repertoire quite
frankly and we have such a big big day
uh i am here we are live we are going to
be reviewing a number of different
things that took place today we have an
omicron briefing we may all pray at the
altar of omicron today
um we are also standing by for joe biden
with as many i am not a christian
um but i know enough christians to know
that if you don't have cheaply produced
chinese tchotchkes for christmas
it's a very bad christmas and so joe
biden is expected to weigh in he's
actually 45 minutes late already
joe biden will be weighing in on the
supply chain crisis ahead of the holiday
season because we remember the
rebirth no christmas is the birth right
christmas is the birth or the rebirth of
jesus
easter is the rebirth right
what is it the birthday
christmas
obviously
the birth of jesus
and cheap chinese tchotchkes
often made from plastic and other
polymer elements
are
they go hand in hand and so if you don't
have the tchotchkes it's not really
christmas
yeah okay so we're standing by for that
from joe biden we did get an update from
the president earlier today about
omicron and we are going to look at the
wh os update on omicron we're going to
look at the press briefing today during
which uh peter ducey
again tried to do gotcha stuff
andrew yang may have attacked me for a
question he
basically messed up during our interview
last week
we are going to be doing unbans i have
new memetic elements i am going to
actually
we have a very serious instance of what
is often known as meme jacking that took
place i am actually calling it something
else i'm calling it memetic grand
larceny
memetic grand larceny which is
this is a really big day and in addition
to everything i've just told you i have
a new audio element that i want you guys
to tell me whether it should go on the
sound board elements of bathrooms and i
also am going to
open phone lines if we get to 100
members and twitch subs because we
haven't done it in so long all right so
let's first get caught up there some
incredible people are participating
right now
and those people are named
uh oh deeper shades of house dj lars
baron roth re-upping his sub beth graham
and pink and blonde
signing up via twitch prime putting us
okay so three out of a hundred that's
three divided by ten is point three zero
divided by zero is zero point three
times one hundred
is uh that's like eighty percent of the
way there right
three out of a hundred that's like
eighty or eighty five percent of the way
there if anybody can check my my math on
that
um okay let's get the unban request out
of the way right now
oh and yes today's coupon code is obama
you can use it for a 68 discount we have
a user
who showed up in the chat
on um
the day before thanksgiving i guess
and they did the following
uh chat
let's go brandon let's go brandon let's
go brandon let's go brandon let's go
brandon let's go brandon let's go
brandon let's go brandon let's go
brandon let's go brandon let's go
brandon
all caps i should add
they were banned
and they asked to be unbanned with the
message come on man
that is a deny and a perma-ban
too easy guys
too easy
another user
named meaty4
showed up
and said oh wait a second oh my god we
just had an explosive situation
is there a hype train going something
crazy is happening jen here dark horizon
crow bars forever endes and mr vister
just dropped in twitch prime
subscriptions oh and we're in the middle
of a level three hype train i'm actually
shocked okay here's another user
they showed up
and they said cringe
praise god
amen
david pakman attacking religion yikes
shush david
they were banned
they then said in their unban request i
apologize i was being intentionally
trollish
i don't know if that's worthy of an
unban i mean they're basically saying we
were right to ban them
unbanned okay all right fine i'll unban
i'll adjudicate that
unbanned
and we'll give them another opportunity
so that's it as far as unban requests
are concerned i also want to say thank
you to joe k44
blast hard chaise
and cyborg for the twitch subs putting
us at 11.
thanks very much guys i appreciate that
um i do have a voicemail from jimmy from
philly that i want to mention just play
real quick to get us off off to a good
start david jimmy from philly
so i just watched your pacman live video
where
somebody suggests that you start a wack
pack
and i would have no problem with that
but henceforth
i would have to be referred to
as the psychedelic king
of all retards oh yeah we don't use the
term retards pejoratively on this
channel so that that wouldn't work
unfortunately um so jimmy i'm going to
take a pass on that i do appreciate you
with the incredibly generous offer but
that's just not something we do
i want to say thanks to christina willis
christina willis is the first person
today to sign up on my website with the
coupon code obama obama and his new
member number 12 today you know what
since we're on the topic of obama let me
get right into that first and foremost
as many of you know we've been on this
obama meme for a very long period of
time now i don't i am not a let me i
want to make sure i'm i have clarity
this evening i am not aware of any
channel that has picked up on obama
before we did okay and it all comes from
this remember this if ted doesn't win
your second amendment is going to be in
trouble big trouble remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama
amnesty
amnesty obama
okay so that those are the oranges of
that meme
last week i get an email
and the email says
david
molina destiny bonnell ii
is meme jacking
she jacked obama from you and case in
point i went over to the molina destiny
[ __ ] i'm sorry molina destiny bennell
and i'm not subscribed to this so i
can't even see it but
this one right here
there are a number of different i
believe they're tts elements in the
lower left
and one of them is two subs it says
obama i i think that it's like a tts
where if you donate two subs you here
okay now i'm not claiming ownership over
the meme
memes are ethereal and
uh
yeah okay but anyway so i went in the
chat and i said molina where did this
obama thing come from and she goes
some of steve's people brought it over
it was from the destiny people so the
dgg community committed memetic grand
larceny took obama
and now have moved it over to molina
destiny bonnell the second channel and i
even have another example of it i don't
know who these people are
but this guy in the lower left is
talking this is one of these you know
nine person debates that goes on for
three hours who the hell knows and here
this guy casually mentions obamacare and
i can't tell if he's now just casually
using it take a listen to this
right now in terms of control between
democrats and republicans right when
we're talking about it
when we're talking about the things like
the repeal on obamacare the reason why
it was so difficult
obamacare that's guppy it looked guppy i
can't tell it's like behind my thing
um
so listen i don't know i it's j it's
just like
um
vaush stole enlightened centrist from me
um and then now destiny guppy and melina
have stolen obama
i am taking this as uh i believe this is
the sincerest form of flattery to be
perfectly frank that's the way i'm
taking it i'm not even mad uh i it's uh
i'm glad to have been able to get some
of these trends going all right guys
thank you very much everybody i want to
say thanks to sven anderson as well as
asf clops for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 14.
i did mention at the top of the stream
because there is going to be a dearth of
live streams in december because of a
lot of different things that are going
on um and this may be one of the last
live streams for a while
i would uh i'm open to doing live calls
today and we will do it if we get to a
hundred website members and twitch
subscribers you can sign up on my
website joinpakman.com with the coupon
code obama all right other things super
chats coming in papi says what do you
think about nuclear powered cars i know
nothing about nuclear-powered cars but
i would uh
react that it sounds impractical
a couple people recommending that we
claim some of these memes on know your
meme oh i would love that
let's if people know how to do that
let's absolutely try to claim these
uh i think it's very very important to
do kevin mccombs says elements of
memetical exactly that's different than
elements of medical
elements of medical we're talking about
elements of memetical here that's
absolutely right okay we're still
standing by for joe biden let's get
right to the briefing on omicron okay
let's get right into it and then we're
going to look at what the who says i
believe that it is not the right time to
panic we still don't know so many things
about it let's listen to what joe biden
had to say today
good morning folks
hope you all had it and we will listen
to it just because we can
on
1.25 x okay thank you everybody
thanksgiving able to get together with
your family and friends
and actually at 1.25x biden sounds
normal so i like it
it was great to see uh so many families
getting together this thanksgiving after
being a part last year
and we have much to be grateful for as a
nation
when i was elected i said i would always
be honest with you so today i want to
take a few moments to talk about the new
covet variant first identified last week
in southern africa it's called the
omnicron
it is a so it is not called omnicron it
is actually called omacron it is not
omnicron just to make everybody
we're talking about omicron not omnicron
yeah to their credit the scientific
community in south africa quickly
notified the world of the emergence of
this new variant
and as a result we've banned all flights
flights to and from congratulations to
them transparency is to be encouraged
and applauded because it increases our
ability to respond quickly to any new
threats and that's exactly what we did
the very day the world health
organization identified the new variant
i took immediate steps to restrict
travel from countries in southern africa
but while we have that travel
restrictions can slow the speed of
omnicron it cannot prevent it but here's
what it does that's our set we actually
need uh so small fuzzy moss let's make
notes we need omnicron on the sound
board
it gives us time gives us time to take
more actions to move quicker to make
sure people understand you have to get
your vaccine you have to get the shot
you have to get to get the booster if
you're sooner or later we're going to
see cases of this new variant here in
the united states we'll have to face
this new threat just so we face those
that come before it
today there are three messages about the
new variant that i want the american
people to hear
first
this variant is a cause for concern not
a cause for panic
we have the best vaccine in the world
one of the best medicines the best
scientists and we're learning more every
single day and we'll fight this variant
with scientific and
and knowledgeable actions and speed not
chaos and confusion and we have more
tools today to fight the variant than
we've ever had before
from vaccines to boosters to vaccines
for children five years and older and
much more
a year ago america was floundering
against the first variant of covet we
beat that variant significantly and then
we got hit by a far more powerful threat
the delta variant but we took action and
now we're seeing deaths from delta come
down
we'll fight the you know and look we're
going to fight and beat this new variant
as well we're learning more about this
new variant every single day and as we
learn more we're going to share that
information with the american people
candidly and promptly
second
the best protection i know you're tired
hear me say this the best protection
against this new variant or any of the
of the variants out there but the ones
we've been dealing with already is
getting fully vaccinated and getting a
booster shot
most americans are fully vaccinated but
not yet boosted
if you're 18 years old i've been very
strongly boosted just so everybody knows
over and got fully vaccinated before
june the first go get the booster shot
today
they're free and they're available at 80
000 locations coast to coast
a fully vaccinated booster person is the
most protected against covet
do not wait go get your booster if it's
time for you to do so
and if you are not vaccinated now is the
time to get vaccinated and take your
children to be vaccinated right every
child age five or older can get safe
effective vaccines now
while it will be a few weeks before we
know everything we need to know about
how strongly the existing vaccines
protect against the new variant dr fauci
is with me today our medical team
and believe that the vaccines will
continue to provide a degree of
protection against severe disease yeah
we're going to talk about what we know
about that
in a moment
and as additional protections please
wear your mask when you're indoors in
public settings around other people it
protects you it protects those around
you
third
in the event hopefully unlikely that
updated vaccinations or boosters are
needed to respond to this new variant we
will accelerate their development and
employment with every available tool
i want to reiterate dr fauci believes
that the current vaccines provide at
least some protection against a new
variant and the booster strengthen that
protection significantly
we do not yet believe that additional
measures will be needed
but
so that we are prepared if needed my
team is already working with officials
at pfizer and berdern and johnson and
johnson to develop contingency plans for
vaccines or boosters if needed
and i will also direct the fda and the
cdc to use the fastest process available
without cutting any corners for safety
to get such vaccines approved and on the
market if needed
and we'll do that the same way any
modifications are needed or current
treatments need used to help those with
who get ill with the covet virus look
i'm uh i'm sparing no effort i'm
removing all roadblocks to keep the
american people safe
all of this is confusing to a lot of
people but if it's confusing to you let
me close with this simple message
if you are vaccinated but still worried
about the new variant get your booster
if you aren't vaccinated get that shot
go get that first shot
my team at the white house will provide
me with daily updates this week on
thursday i'll be putting forward a
detail strategy outlining how we're
going to fight coven this winter not
with shutdowns or lockdowns but with
more widespread vaccinations boosters
testing and more
i promised every american that there
will be always be the latest vaccines
available and the booster shots
available to them and for free and
everywhere available every single
american free of charge and i will keep
that commitment but we need to do more
than vaccinate americans to beat the
pandemic we have to vaccinate the world
as well
and america is leading that effort we've
shipped for free more vaccines to other
countries than all other countries in
the world combined
over 275 million vaccines to 110
countries
now we need the rest of the world to
step up as well let me be clear
not a single vaccine shot americans ever
sent to the rest of the world will ever
come at the expense of any american i
will always make sure that our people
are protected first
but vaccinating the world is just one
more tool and how we need to meet our
moral obligation as americans and how to
best protect americans as well the delta
variants and now the omnicron variant
all emerged elsewhere in the world
so we can't i don't know why i just love
omnicron set up until the world is
vaccinated we're protecting americans by
doing that as well as we continue this
effort let's remember where we stand
we're in a very different place as we
enter the month of december this month
compared to where we were last uh last
september last christmas
last christmas fewer than one percent of
american adults were vaccinated this
christmas the number will be over 71
percent including more than 86 percent
of seniors last christmas our children
were at risk without a vaccine this
christmas we have safe and effective
vaccines for children ages 5 and older
with more than 19 million children and
counting now vaccinated last year a
majority of schools were closed this
year 99 of our schools are open let me
reiterate once more we also now have
booster shots that provide extra
protection
they're free and convenient there is
still time to get your first two shots
or your booster shot or get your
children vaccinated before christmas all
three are available can be done before
christmas if you and your family are
fully vaccinated you can celebrate the
holidays much more safely and given
where we were last year that's a
blessing that none of us should take for
granted we're throwing everything we can
at this virus tracking it from every
angle all right that's what we have so i
think you guys sort of get the picture
here uh i don't know if does dr fauci
say anything yes he does okay let's
listen to the fouchy portion about
what's being done
doc
thank you mr president we already have
in place when people come into the
united states they have to be tested
before they get on and they have to show
vaccination uh uh documentation so even
before omnicorn came in we have a
situation where we'll be able to test
then talking did touchy also call it
omnicron what is going on huh
testing
for fortunately for us the pcrs that we
mostly use would pick up this very
unusual variant i guess we don't need
the sped up audio for fouchy that's a
fair point
it's a real large constellation of
mutations fortunately for us that the
pcrs that we do do pick it up
and uh
we're following extremely closely the
medical community of the kova team
uh
any
developments as it relates to how severe
it is how quickly due to how quickly it
spreads how dangerous it is etc we have
more work all right um
good so that was the biden briefing
there
um as we stand by for the next biden
briefing let's actually look at the
who's update on omicron now you guys if
you are if you're a member and you've
already gotten my podcast and all of
that stuff you would already know it
um but as i said before this variant may
be very bad in a number of different
ways it may have some degree of vaccine
evasion or a significant degree
it might be more likely to lead to
hospitalization it might be more likely
to lead to death we just don't know that
it is yet and until we do it makes sense
to
not go crazy and not uh not not panic uh
so update on omicron current knowledge
okay
transmissibility it is not yet clear
whether omicron is more transmissible
okay we're looking at it
the number of people testing positive
has risen in areas of south africa
affected by this variant but
epidemiologic studies are underway to
understand if it is because of omicron
or other factors all right so we don't
know
severity of disease it is not clear
whether infection with omicron causes
more severe disease compared to
infections with other variants including
delta
preliminary data suggests there are
increasing rates of hospitalization in
south africa but this may be due to
increasing overall numbers of people
becoming infected rather than a result
of specific infection with omicron okay
so we don't know yet
effectiveness of prior infection
preliminary evidence suggests there may
be an increased risk of reinfection with
omicron
as compared to other variants but
information is limited
we don't know
effectiveness of vaccines who is working
with technical partners to understand
the potential impact on vaccines
okay we just don't know effectiveness of
current tests as dr fauci just said
there the widely used pcr tests continue
to detect infection including infection
with omicron
studies are going ongoing to determine
whether there's any impact on other
types of tests including the antigen we
don't know
effectiveness of current treatments
corticosteroids and il6 receptor
blockers will still be effective for
managing patients with severe cova-19
other treatments will be assessed to see
if they are still as effective given the
changes to the parts of the virus in the
omicron variant okay so there's so much
stuff that we just don't know right now
that's the update and so
going crazy
yet doesn't really make a lot of sense
now let's see david leonhart has a new
york times article about it
um
omicron let's he's very good so let's
see if we can look at that
10 hours ago what should you assume
about the new variant okay good let's
pull that up i think that that's
relevant to look
at i do by the way
want to say thank you
to kind af
and jen here jen here has gifted two
subs also thanks to shem whistler
for the sign ups that puts us at 18
also big thank you to christian stafford
who just made a 50 pledge via patreon
patreon count double putting us at 20
and thanks also to alyssa cooney who
just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code obama
and his new member number 21 today we
will open phone lines uh if we are
lucky enough lucky enough to get to
100 for the day
all right let's look at the article from
david leonhart from the new york times
what should you assume about the new
variant this is good this is from this
morning
all right let's see
public reaction has followed a familiar
cycle people assume the worst about two
different questions whether the variant
leads to faster transmission
of the covet virus and whether it causes
more severe illness
among infected people
the first of the worries came true with
alpha and delta alpha was more
contagious than the original virus delta
was even more contagious than alpha but
the second of the worries has largely
not been borne out with both alpha and
delta the percentage of coveted cases
that led to hospitalization or death
held fairly steady
this pattern isn't surprising scientists
say viruses often evolve in ways that
help them flourish becoming more
contagious allows a virus to do so
becoming more severe has the potential
to do the opposite because more of a
viruses hosts can die before they infect
others it's too soon to know whether
omicron will fit the pattern but the
very early evidence suggests it may
unfortunately omicron seems likely to be
more contagious than delta including
among vaccinated people fortunately the
evidence so far does not indicate it's
causing more severe illness okay now
these are some of the anecdotal things
that have been said
barry shub south african virologist says
omicron cases have tended to be mild to
moderate
good sign but early days
dr rudo
mativa
the head of intensive care at a hospital
in soweto says severe cases have been
concentrated among people not vaccinated
dr sharon alroy price
from israel
says vaccinated people when vaccinated
people were infected they became only
slightly ill
and the times carl zimmer writes for now
there's no evidence
that omicron
causes more severe disease
a lot of worst case scenarios genuine
uncertainty
should be taken seriously
absent new evidence the rational
assumption is covet is likely to stay
mild among the vaccinated unless
health is precarious
for most vaccinated people covid
probably presents less risk than some
everyday activities
fauci emphasized the power of
vaccination it may not be as good but
it's been important
to diminish how likely you are to get
very sick
um
epidemiologist caitlin jetelina said do
not take omicron lightly but don't
abandon hope either our immune systems
are incredible
none of this changes what you can do
ventilate spaces use mass test isolate
get vaccinated get boosted
um
yeah we've just gotta yeah ship vaccines
to africa
yes so but more or less all of the same
stuff that that we've been talking about
so no big surprise there
and uh all makes perfect sense so far
some people say david if it's time to
panic will you tell us i mean i guess
even if it's very serious i don't know
that we benefit from panicking
you know
uh
but that's sort of another story
altogether
um let's look at a few super chats here
obamicron
yeah
what's your favorite sandwich filling oh
i like so many sandwiches i couldn't
possibly tell you
couldn't pick one oh speaking of
sandwiches alert here for small fuzzy
moss here's another interesting element
that i think might be good for our um
sound board
over the weekend i was back in uh the
boston area for the holiday
and when i'm up there i love to go to
michael's deli in brookline as i said
before when i lived up there i would
regularly go i went and i got myself a
brisket on light rye with a pickle and
as i am eating it you can hear a shout
in the background
two corned beefs on pumpernickel with
sauerkraut and i think it's a fantastic
element for our food related sound board
take a listen tell me what you think
[Music]
what do you guys think
two corned beefs on pumpernickel with
sauerkraut any is that a good idea
all right yep so we need that small
fuzzy moss that is a second assignment
for you today that is a very very strong
element we could probably clean it up a
little bit
and it'll make it even better which i
think is great uh i do want to say thank
you to
helen killer for signing up via twitch
prime you were number 22 today very much
appreciated thank you so much all right
do we want to do the oh let's do the
andrew yang thing
actually no let's finish super chats
first
breaking news joe manchin said he wants
paid leave to be bipartisan okay
david should we be worried that the
romneycron variant represents the
republicans latest attempt at violence
against american democracy all right a
lot of omicron jokes
america needs more judge wilmsley's and
less judge schraders you mean fewer
judge schraders fewer
do you think we will ever have a
lockdown again or do you think they'll
resist
i work at an avatar themed simulator in
central florida and the most i see is us
upping precautions yeah i think that
unless it got to like a ten percent
death rate maybe five percent i think
it's extremely extremely unlikely
that um i mean there's just no appetite
for first of all there were never
lockdowns in the us as is being astutely
pointed out but if by lockdowns we mean
no indoor dining and no movie theaters
or whatever
i think there's going to be resistance
to the end
i really do
okay
um
new member robert portner has just
signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 23 today
let's see what else we've got here
a couple other voicemails
uh
oh eric from mass is dumping in
disinformation let's listen to it hey
david and sarah from math um i saw your
trump uh video and it's
um
i disagree i think um his
unveiling of fake news
um and telling the world about that may
be the greatest or one of the greatest
things the president has ever
enlightened a country about man it's
it's just very very dumb
um and then also one from whitney
and what is the [ __ ] that you're giving
the right credit for
which i'm like you know
traditionally known
it's like usually like
pretty like tight-ended when it comes to
strategies of you know women versus men
um
when you guys come over
and you bring this horse [ __ ]
like
oh
it's not okay
well whitney shot out of a cannon today
shot out of a cannon um
and let me see if i have anything else
for you guys as far as voicemails are
concerned
oh another really boring one from troy
york with one of his fake names they've
just gotten so predictable and boring
when you had a caller on your video phil
who uh was criticizing and
he said he was obsessed with the fox
news television program um greg gutfield
and you compared
was not a comedy but trying to be a
comedy show oh who cares it's it's all
so boring it's all so boring
um okay let's get into the andrew yang
controversy
as many of you know i interviewed andrew
yang last week
and um in the interview andrew yang i
believe botched a very simple answer to
whether white supremacists are welcome
in his movement if they want rank choice
voting
uh it was a really simple question
i was surprised by andrew's answer i
think he botched it and it caused a
problem
as a result andrew yang ended up
tweeting some pretty nasty things
and
whether they were about me or not kind
of remains unclear
now
let's start with the clip okay now i'm
actually going to play for you the
question i asked before the question
about white supremacy
just to show you that
it was a genuine question
and it followed contextually from the
previous question all right so let me
set the stage for you this is from the
interview with andrew yang most frequent
question i got in different iterations
was
who exactly that currently considers
themselves to be on the right
does andrew yang imagine bringing into
the forward party and to kind of
make it a little more specific you know
we would imagine that there's lots of
progressive democrats more centrist
democrats even some folks who really
consider themselves centrist maybe in
the kind of line of even like a john
mccain who like the idea of some of the
reforms you're talking about and that
all kind of makes sense to me
when i think about people who believe
donald trump won the election
vaccines
the covet vaccine magnetizes you causes
autism whatever the case may be
etc right you know the package of ideas
that i'm talking about
one are are those people that would even
conceivably say this forward party idea
that andre yang proposes in a coalition
with the left makes sense and number two
are these even people that you want as
part of your coalition
first let me say i want everyone as part
of the coalition you know if you can
vote we can disagree on a lot of things
uh it's all to the good if we okay so
you heard the answer right he wants
everyone
i that that's not how i would that's
that wouldn't be my perspective okay so
that's his answer his answer is i would
want everyone i want the vaccine
magnetizes people those people i want
everybody all right so then i followed
up agree on the fact that this duopoly
is uh not working is designed to turn us
against each other and sink us so that
that's one of the principles of the ford
party is that look i can disagree with
you on a lot of stuff but if we can make
common cause on this then we can go back
to disagreeing when the democracy is
actually set up to succeed when they're
you know
so let me i mean let me ask so even i
mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the
republican party is too centrist i'm an
extreme white supremacist or something
like that but i think we need to get you
know we need single transferable vote or
whatever and campaign you you you still
welcome that because you're on the same
page on that one issue now this is a
direct follow-up to when i said
the anti-vaxx
the vaccine causes autism people
the all this you want those and he's
like i want everybody so now i follow up
with a specific example he should be
able to answer this
yeah if they're going to help us
transition to a more effective democracy
um but you know i don't need to know
what their stance is on things that i
disagree with people have a sense of
where i'm coming from okay
but right now i believe that there is
an existential threat to the country so
i think that that's a botched answer now
how would i have botched the answer okay
how would i have answered the question
to avoid botching it rather my instinct
if i were him and i was asked this
question would be to say
i have denounced white supremacy
countless times and i have to tell you
i don't think any white supremacists
would be interested in what i offer it's
not just about the fact that i want rank
choice voting and campaign finance
reform but if you look at all of my
positions on cultural issues the fact
that i'm asian
white supremacists are not going to be
interested in what i want and i'm not
going out looking for white supremacists
that's how i would have answered the
question he answered it by saying yeah
sure but i don't like white supremacy
okay
and then we moved on this was a
24-minute interview
and this was a genuine follow-up based
on what he said that's it
that's it okay
so then the next day i see this
i didn't think this needed stating but
people who hold ideologies such as white
supremacy that are antithetical to grace
and tolerance are not welcome in the
forward party
our movement for democracy reform is
fighting to diminish harmful extremism
great okay so he clarifies
but then look at this
relatedly this kind of manufactured
controversy is the kind of thing that is
dragging down our public discourse and
distracting from the true issues at hand
he gave a bad answer racist is not the
path to enlightenment
okay so listen i don't know if he was
referring to me when he said that but
this is the answer that he should have
given so you know i tweeted
assuming this tweet is a response to the
question i asked i hope it needs no
clarification that i was not attempting
to manufacture controversy i asked the
question completely genuinely after
reading the book um as we as as
hopefully you guys just saw
it wasn't even on my list of questions
it was a follow-up based on his answer
that everyone is welcome even the
anti-vaxx people so some people wrote
back and said david he wasn't attacking
you he was attacking people on twitter
who took his answer and then called him
a racist i wasn't the one calling him a
race okay if that's the case then fine
um but you know i i don't know to what
extent he was uh
he was referring to to me there
um
okay so that's the andrew yang thing i
don't know that we necessarily have to
go further with it uh but that's uh that
is what it is i want to say thank you to
alice maravias who just signed up via
twitch prime and his new member number
24 today i really appreciate that alice
i also want to say
uh
thank you to i'm going to be very
careful pronouncing this this is a user
i'm going to call
imaf tujin
imaf toujin
who signed up at joinpakman.com with the
coupon code obama
and his new member number 25 today which
i very much appreciate i would love it
if you signed up today at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code at your
pleasure at your leisure
etc etc
okay
couple of other things here
uh what was this
oh yeah oh look at this
we're gonna talk about this on the show
tomorrow
in this clip
this is anchor john scott from fox news
and on the right is um the the
editor-in-chief of the washington
examiner which is a right-wing rag
they are now attacking joe biden because
the vaccination rate is low
now of course part of the reason the
vaccination rate is low
is since joe biden became president fox
news has been
kowtowing to anti-vax ideas and now
they're saying not enough people are
vaccinated well
you're part of the reason why take a
listen to this it's like you it's beyond
parody
and yet uh this year we have lost more
people in this country to covid uh than
we did during the the first year of the
pandemic when donald trump was president
and and now we have the vaccines
exactly so exactly so the the pandemic
exploded in march of 2020 which was 10
months before donald trump was out of
office
president biden by coincidence now has
been in office for 10 months more people
have died under president biden than
under president trump and biden
inherited the vacci the vaccines
you know he he he came into office
promising that he was going to get his
arms around this in a way that the
previous administration had not but his
uh but you know vaccination rate is only
58 percent here considerably lower than
in other places
so he hasn't got his arms around it and
as i say what this is is just a way of
looking like he's doing something
meaningful but in fact not not managing
this thing very well at all well he
pledged that he was going to get 70
percent of the country vaccinated why
hasn't that happened hasn't happened uh
you know if people don't want to get the
vaccine and i am one who has been
vaccinated but if people don't want to
get the vaccine uh can you blame can you
imagine
uh now like listen we've only got 58
percent back we're actually at 59 i
think they said 58. um you know joe
biden has failed well it's your channel
that is convincing people not to get
vaccinated
it's you you you can't satirize this
it's it's completely bonkers and if you
try to i mean good luck explaining that
to them
um let me see what else i had oh there's
a little bit of a controversy going on
with sam cedar yesterday i went to the
grocery store and they were out of
granny smith's for the first time ever
never in my adult life have i seen a
grocery store out of my beloved granny
smith apples
until today sad times
sam cedar jumped in out of nowhere oh no
sam cedar what sam who exactly and sam
said
the fact that they have never been sold
out before should be a clue as to their
appeal sam is very very aggressive
against
granny smith's
to which i responded
the fact that it's the only sold out
apple
might be a more important clue so in
demand so in demand
that it actually became sold out i think
that's the right perspective
so a little bit of a drama alert there
oh no sam cedar
and then lastly
as part of his victory tour and being
made a hero
kyle rittenhouse went
to speak to charlie kirk
what do you think is under written
house's shirt right here do you guys see
this like what is that
is it a device is he wearing some kind
of bulletproof vest i can't tell what it
is
a dog tag okay
anyway
um
this was really funny someone modified
an old trump tweet
about a different male politician and
put in charlie kirk's
name charlie kirk looked disgusting
nipples protruding in his blue shirt
before congress very very disrespectful
and uh referring to this picture
um very very subtle
very very subtle trolling which we do we
do like very much so that's um
very nicely done element that i liked
significantly i don't know who does
anybody remember who it was about
originally some member of congress i
don't really remember who it was
yeah i don't remember
i do want to say thank you to nat rast
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code obama
and his new member number 26 today let's
look a little bit
at today's white house press briefing
about omicron and other questions let's
listen
he talked about the need for boosters
does the white house not only plan to
ramp up its promotion of boosters beyond
what we've seen from the president sure
let me start with the timeline because i
think this is an important people piece
for the american people to understand
what the process is and what the
scientists are working on so
first and foremost as you all know we
have a top-notch set of group of
scientists across the country already
set up to do this work and they are
working in close coordination with
scientists and medical experts
around the world and you saw that
coordination happen over the last
several days so uh you know one of the
things that was interesting to watch i
think should be
compelling or encouraging is that
as soon as this variant popped up it was
communicated and coordinated around the
world that information was shared
publicly in a transparent manner that
credit is owed to the south african
leaders there and certainly the
president to answer one of your earlier
questions is committed to continuing to
be transparent with the american people
as we see any cases come up in the
united states and dr fauci and other
medical experts have pointed to the
possibility that that will and could
happen and we will be transparent with
the public and track that closely so let
me go back to how this process works uh
these experts our medical experts uh are
um
are primed to do the work around the
clock uh when you wanna test a virus you
need to isolate it from a swab and
purify it and make sure it is a live
virus and the virus you intended to
study this this takes a couple some days
this all takes days then you need to
grow stock of it to test again days two
weeks and once it's grown you have to
sequence it and make sure it hasn't
mutated again while it grew again days
and finally we need to actually test the
virus with antibodies from vaccinated
people again days the last steps needs
to be repeated because we want to make
sure we've gotten this right so that is
the process quite a process
team is undergoing now because they want
to be able to report back some of the
important questions and unknowns at this
point in time the efficacy of the
vaccines uh and uh what any if any
additional steps are needed to take and
we're prepared to do those what the
american people should know is that the
president is
going to do everything he's going to
always err on the side of protecting the
american people that's why we put in
place the travel restrictions
and we will continue to assess any step
we need to take in order to do exactly
that i may have missed one of your
questions did i miss a question okay
oh boosters and whether we're going to
promote these further well i would say
you heard the president say this earlier
today and we have had uh medical experts
dr fauci and others across the airwaves
and out there in public over recent days
to convey clearly that we know that
boosters can strengthen antibodies in in
the american people there are still tens
of millions of people out there who have
not gotten their booster if people feel
they don't know what to do right now
they're not sure which step they should
take even as they're on there are
unknowns and we acknowledge there are
unknowns we're looking to get to the
bottom of there's no question that
getting a booster will help strengthen
people protect them and we will continue
to uh project that out publicly and then
on the iran nuclear talks that they
resume uh robert malley said signs from
iran all right we're really focusing on
omicron here so maybe we can skip to the
next
question which i think is maybe
here saw by our announcement over the
weekend
our health officials are any additional
steps that need to be taken so our
advice and recommendations continues to
be to watch that closely and follow that
in order to protect your communities
go ahead thank you um i wanted to ask if
the white house was reconsidering the
decision to release strategic reserves
given that oil prices have already gone
down with um variant
we are not reconsidering now
and i was wondering if there was concern
on the part of the us government about
the lack of specifics from beijing on
its part about its own reserve releases
uh again i mean we are always
encouraging any country around the world
including
china
to be as transparent as possible in any
of their policy maneuvers but i don't
have any additional concerns to express
today thank you
what a few on omicron that went on a
domestic matter
the president insisted that the
travel ban on south africa
doesn't punish them in neighboring
countries but south africa's leaders say
it does
how long does the white house envision
that travel ban staying in place
we will continue to assess that i would
say that the objective here is not to
punish it is to protect the american
people as you just heard the president
say
this is not going to prevent is going to
delay and that delay is going to help us
have necessary time to do the research
by our health and medical teams to get
more people vaccinated and get more
people boosted and he's always going to
err on the side of protecting the
american people i would note that the
difference between south africa and
european countries is that there are
already hundreds if not thousands of
cases of the new variant in south africa
and not as many much a lower number at
this point in europe but we will
continue to the cat is out of the bag
guys quite i mean it's at this point i i
just don't i just don't know about the
strategy to assess what steps we need to
take to protect the american people um
are you imposing any new testing or
tracing
on americans or green card holders who
come from those
south southern african countries once
they get here well we already have
stringent requirements in place as you
know a requirement of vaccinations a
vaccination requirement and individuals
need to be tested three days in advance
within three days i should say of
traveling i don't have any additional
requirements or restrictions to preview
aside from the um the
you know current
restrictions on travel from certain
countries there's this trip to minnesota
tomorrow by the president you have all
said that you're going to continue all
right so a pretty uneventful press
conference there were a couple questions
from a peter ducey
and they they weren't even interesting
like i know he always tries to act tough
and and kind of drop these bombs
um but they were really quite boring
i'll play them for you here's the first
one that peter ducey asked today
before joe biden was president he said
that clover travel restrictions on
foreign countries were hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering so what
changed
well i would say first to put it in full
context peter what the president was
critical of was the way that the former
president put out i believe a xenophobic
tweet uh
and how he called that what he called
the cocuronavirus uh and and who he
directed it at the president has not
been critical of
travel restrictions we have put those in
place ourselves we put them in place
ourselves in the spring but no he does
not believe he believes we should uh
follow the advice of health and medical
experts that's exactly what he did and
putting in place these restrictions over
because there's like the answers
mediocre but the questions so boring and
it's just like you know ask something
substantive here's another one of these
he was shopping in a store and on the
glass outside it said face covering
required and we could see him inside and
his face was uncovered well again peter
our recommendation and advice continues
to be for people to wear i mean that
doesn't look great but but it's also
like not the biggest news
masks when they are required in
establishments i don't know what this
establishment was the president
obviously follows the health the advice
of his health and medical team is there
a concern that when the president says
today please wear your masking doors in
public settings around other people and
he doesn't do that that it's going to
make it harder to get people to follow
him i think you see the american people
and all of you see the president wearing
a mask every time he comes out to an
event when he's sitting in meetings and
certainly he will continue to model
behavior he hopes the american people
will follow not for his benefit but to
save their own lives and the lives of
their friends yeah so you guys are
probably as bored by it at this point as
i am i do want to say thanks to chief
boris double07 who just re-upped his
twitch prime subscription with the
message obama
i also want to say a big thank you to
oh no no one i thought someone had
signed up on my website but they didn't
um okay update on the g lane maxwell
trial happening live right now a court
today tom that stood out to you that you
haven't talked about on the air yet
yeah a couple of things but i think the
most important thing is the how clear
each side was focused on their mission
the opening statement given by lara
pomerant's assistant united states
attorney almost dispassionate times but
just laying out what one of these girls
went through according to her and in her
allegations uh this pseudonym of this
name jane who was 14 years old and then
i think for the defense i think bobby
sternheim was very clear this is not the
jeffrey epstein trial today and for the
next six weeks this is going to be a
trial about gelane maxwell it does the
government do prosecutors have enough
evidence to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt so those were two kind of key
moments today definitely a heavy
afternoon in court hallelujah sounds
like it tom winner i'm sure i'll be
talking again uh as you are posted up
there outside that courthouse in new
york appreciate it
breaking tonight prosecutors are asking
the u.s supreme court to review
an appeals court ruling that overturned
bill cosby's 2018 assault conviction
this is just coming into us in the last
couple hours
why well
because of what the d.a calls a
dangerous precedent that could set for
immunity agreements cosby remember
served less than three years of a three
to ten year sentence and then this is
one of the shots of him he was released
from prison at the end of june i want to
bring in now pete williams okay pete
let's break this all right so that's the
uh that's the cosby stuff going on i
want to say thanks to tina tiru and c
missile for the twitch prime
subscriptions today numbers 28 and 29.
let me get back to
um a few of the
voicemails that have been coming in we
did get interrupted when we were looking
at those let's see
uh there was one other from whitney
also when guys say something to you like
i love you it means like props
when
like israel or something says i love you
to me
like even though it's like oh i can see
your german it means you're soft when
you say that to a woman it means like
you know
what
there's like something
on the inside
i can see or something like that oh man
i don't know what she is talking about
that's very very common
um more anti-vaxxed nonsense from eric
from mass
hey david eric from mass
slovenia
whistleblowing nerfs comes out admits
all politicians get saline rather than
the vaccine oh give me a break dude
um
just really really wacky stuff
thanks to blueberry babe for gifting a
subscription on twitch number 30 today
here's another troy york character this
one named wally jackson
hey uh david this is wally jackson
i
want to congratulate you on hearing you
on the actual radio i guess you're an
official broadcaster
and
i strongly disagree with your comment
about
jonah goldberg and some other guy that
no one's ever heard of no one cares
uh them leaving fox is no big deal
um i knew you were gonna do a little
video on this
man what a boring boring caller
[Music]
dear god
couldn't now then he called back in as
his i guess his black character jamal
jenkins
uh david pakman this is jamal from
university park
illinois and i saw your interview with
andrew yang
and i want to know as a guest suggestion
i'm going to give you another guest
suggestion of
uh instead of having angry yang
on all the time this is like the fifth
or sixth time you've had mine i think
this is the third time yang's been on
the first time in three years
um when are you going to have
andrew nick on your show andrew zigg
that is not someone i'm familiar with i
must say
um
maybe we just do no more troy york stuff
at all i mean it's just it's gotten so
pedantic
um
i do have i do have more uh
whitney stuff
david look at alexandria cortez for
example because she attacks
ivanka when it's like ivanka she was
going after like some art that she
was selling
um to her family her family like peter
like that's pretty torturous guys i do
want to say thanks to potato
for signing up via twitch and gifting
five subs which puts us at 36. also
thanks to multibeast
who has subscribed for 20 months and
says
always worth reminding people twitch
prime subs do not automatically renew
also honeycrisp apples are the best i'll
accept that being said
um as long as the renewal admonishment
is included there i think that that's
completely fine i also want to say
thanks to jennifer baldi who signed up
on my website with the coupon code obama
and that is new member number 38. all
right everybody that's everything i had
for today i will be back tomorrow
there's a few different important news
elements taking place tomorrow i will be
streaming tomorrow will be the last
stream of the month
why
because it's the last day of the month
go figure alright everybody we'll be
back tomorrow see everybody very soon
you